[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie Kevin Feige
just did a new interview about Avengers
4 in Captain Marvel we learned about her
new origin story in the MCU so break
everything down if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get all the Comic Con videos there's a
new giveaway stuff I'll explain at the
end of the video the biggest thing first
Kevin Feige talking about the definitive
ending to this sort of 10-year block of
films it'll be 22 films after Avengers 4
so I'm quoting him when someone asked
him if the changes we see to the
characters in the universe that happened
during infinity war in Avengers 4 are
gonna stick he said and I'm quoting him
I would say almost all of them are
permanent changes meaning they will roll
some things back like we know that Black
Panthers coming back we know that
spider-man's coming back we pull
examples from comics all the time I
would say in the comics sometimes
characters come back to life the next
day and sometimes characters that they
swore would never come back like Bucky
Barnes will never come back to life come
back and it's awesome like in Winter
Soldier he's saying that they did that
when a comic books came out but they
didn't actually say that when they
killed Bucky offer supposedly killed him
off during the first Captain America
movie he's a little bit smarter about
the way he scenes story ideas that they
can grow into really big movies later on
if they want to he then goes on to say
this is actually interesting I don't
know what's going to happen in five
years or ten years but in terms of the
more immediate future that we're
building and creating right now they
will be finite meaning that some of the
characters they kill off the big
characters will stay dead after Avengers
4 and they probably won't bring back in
new characters will come in and take the
mantle I know people starting to get
worried about Captain America now don't
worry he actually goes on and talks more
about this he does confirm that Avengers
4 is tonally very different from
infinity war infinity war was mostly
them being ten steps behind at every
turn and getting their asses handed to
them and it's just really depressing
ending like we were prepared we weren't
a team Thanos was victorious half of all
life was destroyed whether or not you
think that Thanos was right when he says
he doesn't know what's gonna happen in
five to ten years that's because a
little while ago he did another
interview where he said that they have
the solid next four years
mapped out with the movies that they're
gonna be making now that doesn't assume
any changes that they make to that
roster once the x-men come in because
recently Comcast backed off and they
still have to pass the Justice
Department test like they still have to
go through the government to approve
this big buyout that's happening with
Disney and Fox but assuming that that
all goes well they might change some of
the movies later in that schedule I've
already done a couple videos about that
I'll link one of them at the end of this
there's so much that we can talk about
for phase four
but Feige goes on to talk about the
ending of Avengers 4 the way they leave
things and how they're gonna continue
with the future movies in the next 10
years to thread everything back to these
beginnings so he says yes it's a world I
hope continues into the far future the
same way all these storylines have
continued in the comics but storylines
can come to an end the best stories do
come to an end
Return of the Jedi which he cites was an
ending for a long time and as a
ten-year-old in 1983 he's talking about
himself Kevin Feige was 10 years old
when he saw Return of the Jedi
he said that ending carried me through
30-plus years until there was a sequel
he was talking about force awakens that
hasn't happened before in the superhero
genre he says one of the reasons why
they don't get that really definitive
ending like Return of the Jedi was for
the Star Wars franchise for a long time
was is because a new actor comes in and
a new storyline starts right away
pointing at Andrew Garfield Tobey
Maguire and Tom Holland two separate
reboots within the span of 10 years as
opposed to Star Wars as 30-plus years
gap so he's saying that they did want to
give a definitive ending to these
characters with Avengers 4 he goes on to
say this is actually really important
the universe the world many of the
characters we've introduced will
continue onward in unexpected ways he's
already confirmed what some of those
unexpected ways are but he does say that
some of the pre-existing characters that
phase one Avengers he doesn't totally
have plans for going forward he just
knows that they'll continue
they don't have definitive movie ideas
yet I'll explain which is which the
movies that he has confirmed in the
characters that he knows are coming back
but he doesn't know what their movies
are gonna be then he goes on to talk
about the Captain Marvel movie and her
new origin story I'll explain that in a
second but just to clear up that of
dangers forced up so the characters that
he said are coming back definitely black
widow definitely Thor we know they're
gonna do movies for both those people
Ironman is implied to be coming back
I've already done a video about deleted
scenes there was a deleted scene we're
happy and they were talking about the
wedding that they were planning on
having in that scene before Doctor
Strange showed up so I think that's
backdoor confirmation that their story
ends in Avengers 4 with that Tony Pepper
wedding and that's one of the big events
that brings all the Marvel characters
together like he invites everybody
including Hank Pym and Janet Van Dyne
then some of the characters that he's
not totally sure about are some of the B
characters like Falcon will probably
come back but we don't know where he's
gonna pop up but people like Captain
America Captain America's mantle will
come back but he's not totally sure what
they're gonna do with the Captain
America character if they're gonna
recast it or if they're just gonna put
him on a shelf for a while and then
recast way down the road when we're
talking about real endings though it's
not like these characters are all gonna
die he's just gonna have them take a
back seat in the drama that's revolved
around them the last couple of movies
like all the stuff in Civil War Tony
being pissed off about the death of his
parents that'll all be tabled for the
drama that the new characters will bring
in like Captain Marvel and now the
Spider Man character future big Avengers
team-up sin like the big phase stories
that build towards whatever big secret
war story we get down the road will
revolve around the consequences of the
stuff that these new characters do so
that means the Tony Stark can still come
in and help out every once in a while
but as like a main character you're
probably not gonna see a whole lot of
Robert Downey jr. after this he'll just
pop up every once in a while quit help
people with a problem then go away like
about as much of him as you saw during
spider-man homecoming just there to help
out but it's really spider-man's film
moving into Captain Marvel territory so
Kevin Feige confirmed that they were
going into the nineties because it was
untouched and they wanted to tell a
story when Nick Fury didn't know about
all this crazy alien space war stuff
that was going on he specifically named
Rob kree-skrull war so we confirmed that
that would be the big conflict that was
the backdrop for the movie that served
is the reason for Marvel coming to
Planet Earth but the writer said a
couple months ago that they would be
doing a new backstory for Carol Danvers
without
completely changing her original comic
book origin story so if you haven't read
it there was a brand new comic called
the life of Captain Marvel that was
released just today the sort of details
some of her new origin story now it's
not the entire story but it deals more
with her childhood trauma experienced at
the hands of her father like she lived
in kind of a broken home so if you're
not familiar with the character she's
one of the alcoholic Avengers she and
Tony Stark accidentally bump into each
other in AAA meetings every once in a
while like oh god I didn't know this was
the meeting that you were coming to they
make a couple jokes about that but Carol
reconnects with her family and she
starts to find things that her father
had left behind he's dead in present-day
she learns that he'd been having an
affair with someone we don't know with
who but then she finds a Creed device
that sets off a beacon setting off a
chain of events that leads to this Kree
baby this gestating in space to make its
way back to Planet Earth referencing her
father implying that her father was
involved with the Kree a long time
before Marvel ever came to Planet Earth
and she got into the accident with yon
raw in the psyche magnetron getting her
powers part of me is wondering if
they're trying to imply that her father
was part Kree or a Kree sleeper agent or
he fell in love with the Kree and they
have a Creed child and that's what's
coming to Planet Earth or if Captain
Marvel herself is part Kree because of
the DNA passed on from her father the
way she gets her powers is actually by
being infused with marvel's Kree DNA so
he's this Crees super person with crazy
cosmic powers she gets part of his DNA
that gives her crazy cosmic powers now
they're kind of implying that she might
have Kree DNA that was already a part of
her or her father had some relationship
with someone from the Kree Empire and
that's what precipitated the events that
led to her getting powers so it's not so
much just a random occurrence and
they're trying to give her a more
complex backstory but they'll flesh that
out through this comic book series so
just be on the lookout for a new Marvel
stuff this week they're not at Comic Con
for a big Hall H panel but that doesn't
mean that you're not gonna see movie
stuff we just found out about sinister
six and spider-man far from home so all
kinds of brand-new stuff is dropping all
the time no worries as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you'll see
all the videos there's a new round of
that infinity war blu-ray giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber
and leave a comment on the video so
click here to learn all about sinister
six in spider-man far from home and
click here to watch Tom Holland give
away some of the plot of Avengers 4
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]